so Kelsey tell us what's happening me
and my boyfriend met two years ago at a
party he was so attached to me we've
been inseparable ever since we moved
into a beautiful house we had all these
dreams of like getting married I want
kids but now we've been living in this
house for a year and it's still no rain
Steve we had all these dreams about
getting married no no boo-boo
you had like Martin Luther King said I
have a dream not we own your dream boom
boom so how do I get the ring Steve I'm
here how distasteful but you don't go
see mommy asking for a goddamn ring
that's how you do it he's next to you
talk to him what the hell is you doing
going on Steve are be asking for how do
I get the ring see what the hell is
wrong with you if I hear that's an
example that wouldn't get your ring he's
wrong with you now you just aired your
palms out to the world so all your
friends and family know that you guys
are displeased in your relationship and
now you're getting all of them involved
oh no better no here's a protip to y'all
if you got problems in your relationship
don't air it out to the world because
you don't need a good million voices
getting involved it's already hard
enough to maintain a relationship
between two people when you got me and
him plus a million boo-boo I try to get
into clubs all the time
and you know what secretin to get into
clubs if you want to sneak in don't
bring a million people which because
you're not getting it who you with what
are you saying to her well you know
what's up with all this attitude and
animosity towards them these women look
at their body language oh no I don't I
don't know girl at all if a girl is
holding
we bag you know she got sad I tell her
all the time you know I'm just I'm
enjoying the mama right now we're
building a bond together you know from
that lay of course I don't have a lot of
you know um great positive role models
that are married that we're building a
bond i'ma stop you right there because
you know right away if you want to marry
somebody especially at your age you're
not you know right away what kind of
rinky-dink mother fairy tale do you live
in
[Music]
like you're gonna act like people don't
change
like people do not say that me it's
gonna be battle you're always gonna be
in line with that person all the time
wait wait you guys know right away when
you're gonna find the one person you're
gonna spend the rest of your life with
ruff ladies you don't even know what you
guys want when you go to the in clothing
store the clothing store have you ever
asked them where they want to eat
no no cuz that's not half as infuriating
as going shopping with women because you
don't have a girlfriend
no I'm saying that because I've been
shopping with women ruff women gotta go
shopping they tried everything they put
it back on the Shelf they try all this
they want to try a different sauce
please can you get me this in a smaller
size and can you get this in one size
bigger and you have any accessories I
can go with this and by the end of it we
buy nothing yes but when you shop for
clothes you are reclad clothes on
when you won't eat usually because you
hungry I'll give you that and who are
these ladies that you guys bring it on
to give advice to other people two out
of three of these panelists are still
single and in their forties so why would
I take advice from people who failed at
this thing it's like taking advice from
somebody who's never run a successful
business why would I listen to you about
how to run a business
anybody this man is in a long-term
relationship y'all single as hell is the
Beyonce complex she wrote single ladies
and then she left y'all dancing on
single ladies in the club while she went
back to a man and her two kids all the
single ladies
almost English put your hands up ba well
all your hands were up she went back to
the home if you really have you in a
relationship you ain't got no time do
this you got you got penises to tell you
work hard let's go you didn't just
discover this relationship you've
experienced life I have a hard time when
I hear men saying we're building we're
getting to know each other we've been
here for years well how long does it
take when will you know look how they're
coursing this man and to making a
decision that he's not ready if you're
not happy with
it's taking him you can leave that is
your right you don't have to wait the
same way when I'm trying to get it on
with a girl and she says I'd rather wait
for sex you know what I don't do you
know come on give it up throw that poom
poom at me
yo I'm all that poop I've been here it's
been two dates no if you want if she
wants to later and I don't want to wait
you know what I do I leave deuces it's
unbelievable the entitlement of some
people this is a lifelong commitment you
didn't even take the time to listen to
his reasoning because he talked about
having no positive remarks
maybe the reason why he doesn't want to
engage in marriage and building a family
is that he's being patient because he's
seen what happened when men rush into
things start families and walk out be
patient while we rush it girl you really
just want a ring you really just want
anything that's a ring that's what it is
you won't be able to brag the people
that I got it's a status thing you know
what I mean
I'm I used to like this girl is really
just like I used to play with Barbie
dolls I was supposed to have my can my
pink Corvette my cable and my dog oh and
of course my range it kills me you know
what because marriages disadvantage men
in case of a divorce
it's men who get shafted child custody
it's men who get shafted family courts
it's men who get shafted and so when you
consider all this stuff men have to
propose 100 percent of the marriages
women propose 80% of the divorces we
lose most of the money and yet you still
feel like you're entitled to pressures
into a situation that puts us at risk
think about that slow it down I'm gonna
slow it down even more down over the
marriages per man no no hair is for men
is hey girl I bet you have my we
gonna stay forever together that's what
it is man
glory higher but it's minimum Han let
that sink in the level of entitlement
that you have to have to expect men to
put themselves on the line before you've
proven yourself worthy to our standards
because we're the ones putting up the
risk it's like you and I starting a
business
I've got to put up all the capital and
you're trying to tell me how to make my
decisions um I put up the money you can
which return because if this goes
it's me who loses everything oh man
people are bugging no you know and you
know whether or not you want to do it
right now or not so you know that I want
to just point out and in the moment
process as your girlfriend was talking
about being unhappy you were smiling so
I feel like that's an in congruence in
in in this relationship and you're
withholding smiling because he's on TV
she was stating that she was unhappy she
was smiling but we're not gonna go about
that right good point this is all you
got to say if you want me to continue
the way this is I need a ring and a date
if not I am going back to where I come
from and when you want me
you come and get me I'm looking at them
- right there uh-huh this is the chick
of his dream just top of the line just
to hit jackpot yeah moment she put that
down I'm gonna tell you how I know
Marjorie did it to me I gave her a ring
in December she went home told him about
the ring Walton has got been divorced
twice before his current wife didn't he
know every other time what happened
Steve till death do us part actually
somebody else better came along and
that's what supposed to take advantage
no I did they just supposed to know
where you gonna marry January came she
says so Steve so when are we getting
married I told her I said baby you know
I just got out there divorce
let me clean up a few more things cause
it's a mess hanging out here
she said we can clean it out together I
said no just let me get myself together
she took the ring off she handed it to
me Wow
she said I'll put this on when you let
me put a date on it I took that ring put
that thing back on her hand I said when
you won't get mad
it's unbelievable what passes on TV he's
a mind-blowing sometimes you know
sometimes ladies they hit me up and like
ever why you sound so angry why you
sound so mad when it comes to this stuff
and I try to keep myself in check but
I'll be honest with you guys
it's crazy some of the stuff I hear
people not only allowed to see on TV
about men but also encouraged glorified
it is crazy bro this is honestly insane
to me
these people are advocating for coercion
emotional manipulation it's very
disappointing and I feel like men don't
really have a voice and I was really an
unfair fight because it was three
against what was more than that it was
one two three five against how was the
whole audience - he was alone you know I
mean so it's really hard when you have
pressure like that it we're at he was
about he was on the brink of telling us
something another reality that he has he
was about to tell us his side of the
story and that's why I have a problem
sometimes I have it like if I can't talk
in a situation I shut down I shut down
because the person is not even willing
to listen to you you're willing to
listen to the person the whole thing you
see the girl was able to say the expose
our whole Suraj was about she was about
able to expose her whole thing and when
you're in a conversation and you're not
able to even speak your own words just
to say well this is my perception
sometimes what you say might be not well
constructed or it's hard for you to
express yourself not everybody that have
the same level of expressing themselves
right if you're not even willing to give
me that space I'm not gonna fight for it
I want to put my energy elsewhere you
know what I mean
and that's what's really sad with this
dude he was on the brink of exposing
something that's very crucial to man in
the society like he was basically saying
he does not want to be sure but what
these three experts saw was oh you know
what you were smiling was supposed to do
he on TV the first thing they tell you
is you're on TV you're on camera
while she was expressing herself she was
smiling to know you didn't see that it
was nervousness or anything like that oh
you saw that uh yeah she expressing your
pain and he's smiling and to me that's
that's the that's the thing that's very
sad there's a fact that he's not in this
relationship he's not gonna be able to
express himself and is never gonna be
able to express himself now the people's
expressive is out there because there's
always gonna be that side so it's wet
that's it for today
[Music]
you